in this video we are going to discuss
about jak-stat signaling pathway and
jak-stat signaling pathway is
particularly very important in context
of immunology now the name jack stands
for Janus kinase and the genus is
actually the Greek god of transmission
and as these kinase is Janus kinase is
associated with our cell signal
transduction pathway that is why it is
called Janus kinase kinase and stat
stands for signal transduction and
transmission particle so basically it is
associated with signal transduction so
here we see we have our cell surface
receptors and our ligand comes and bind
to a particular receptor on ligand
binding to one receptor help it to
dimerize you can see it is dimerized
so basically it is 1 it would be
dimerized
and after that dimerize above the
receptor jak kinase get associated with
the c-terminal domain of the receptor
and these jak kinase is not our
intrinsic tyrosine kinase checker the
kinase is extrinsic tyrosine kinase so
it is normally not our integral part of
the site or cytosolic domain of this
receptor so in the step 3 what happens
jack gets associated with the
cytoplasmic domain of the receptor and
jak actually cross phosphorylates each
other so one jak phosphorylates this
jack and this check would phosphorylate
this jack after cross phosphorylating
the activated Jack would actually
phosphorylate the tyrosine residues on
the cytoplasmic c-terminal domain of
that receptor and the phosphotyrosine
residues denoted as P these are the
docking site for step molecules
step molecules could bind to these
regions and they could be dimerized and
that dimerization is a very important
event now the dimerized that can go and
migrate to the nucleus
because you can see this dimerized stat
is getting inside the nucleus and inside
the nucleus there is this particular
stat binding region where a stat can sit
and it can transcribe its target gene
now we would directly jump into the
immunology and see how this check step
signaling is important in context of
immunology
so basically when we talk about T helper
cells we have two type of T helper cells
th1 and th2 the differentiation of T
helper cell into these two th one or pH
two basically depends upon the jak-stat
signaling so when our macrophage so here
we have a macrophage so when our
macrophage is actually activating our
let's say our T helper cell so the
macrophage would first interact with the
T helper cell by its class two MHC and
the T helper cell would interact by its
T cell receptor on the other hand side
the main definitions differentiation
cues are given by the introductions Here
I am representing two type of
interleukin and their signal a signal
mediated by them so here what happens so
here what happens interleukin 2 can bind
to its receptor and interleukin 4 can
also bind to the receptor when
interleukin 2 binds to the receptor its
ultimately activate the stat 4 so upon
ligand binding it activates stack 4 and
stat forget into the nucleus and
actually transcribe a master regulator
called T bit when T bit is the
transcriptional target of stat 4 and it
is transcribed now the th the T helper
cell would be ultimately differentiated
into th one type of cell on the other
hand side if il 4 is bound to the
receptor and stat 6 is activated then
stat 6 would go into the nucleus and it
would transcribe G
th-three and which is actually a master
regulator for th2 differentiation this
is how are two different league and can
use two different stat to regulate
different master regulators and
transcribe different master regulators
and help in the process of t cell
differentiation in this way jacks that
signaling is very important in context
of cell signaling hope you enjoyed the
video please like and subscribe thank
you